Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. One day in February 1651, a man called Jonathan Taylor, a colonist in the new town of Springfield, Connecticut, came home after a hard day's work in the fields to find his wife and daughter already asleep in their one bed by the fireplace. Taking care not to wake them, Taylor crept into bed beside them. But then, with a horrible jolt, he sensed that something was chillingly wrong. He sat up, frozen with terror. Three snakes were slithering across the room towards him. The first glided up the side of the bed, and before Taylor could do anything, it sank its fangs into his forehead.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。1651年2月的一天，康涅狄格州新镇斯普林菲尔德（Springfield）的一位殖民者乔纳森·泰勒（Jonathan Taylor），在田里辛苦劳作了一天后回到家，发现妻子和女儿已经在壁炉边的一张床上熟睡了。泰勒唯恐吵醒他们，轻手轻脚地钻进他们身边的被窝。然而接着，他猛然感到一阵毛骨悚然的惊悸，仿佛有什么极其诡异的事情发生了。他坐起身来，吓得僵在原地。三条蛇正顺着房间的地板向他游来。第一条蛇顺着床边滑了上来，还没等泰勒做出任何反应，它就将毒牙刺进了他的额头。
And then the snake spoke a single word, death. And the really terrifying thing, Tom, was the snake's voice, because it was a voice Taylor recognized. It was the voice of his neighbor, Hugh Parsons. So, Tom, here we are in the dark and paranoid world of Springfield in New England, the world of witch hunting and witch crazes. And we'll get back into this, the details of this incredible tale. Witchcraft in New England, witch hunting, the search for heretics, for evildoers, for bad neighbours, all this stuff.
然后这条蛇吐出了一个字：死。汤姆，真正可怕的是蛇的声音，因为那是泰勒熟悉的声音。那是他的邻居休·帕森斯（Hugh Parsons）的声音。所以，汤姆，我们现在身处新英格兰斯普林菲尔德那黑暗而多疑的世界中，这是一个充满猎巫和猎巫狂热的世界。我们将再次深入探讨这个不可思议的故事的细节。新英格兰的巫术、猎巫行动、搜寻异端、作恶者以及恶邻，等等诸如此类。
It feels like a very rich and resonant subject right now, doesn't it? It absolutely does. And of course, we're at the beginnings of America in the 17th century in New England. And the question of to what extent are future developments in American history being seeded here is a fascinating one. But as you suggested with your gripping account of this expression of witchcraft, I mean, considering that New England is, you know, I mean, it is pretty much, you know, these are a series of virgin colonies pretty much. And meanwhile,
这听起来是一个非常丰富且极具共鸣的主题，不是吗？确实如此。当然，我们正处于17世纪新英格兰美洲的开端。关于美国历史未来的发展在多大程度上是在这里播下种子的，这是一个引人入胜的问题。但正如你通过这段扣人心弦的巫术表象的描述所暗示的那样，考虑到新英格兰基本上是一系列未经开发的处女地殖民地。与此同时，
back in Europe, witch crazes are sweeping Germany and East Anglia and all kinds of places. It is intriguing, I think, that certainly in the imagination of the English speaking world, New England has a particular resonance. So everyone has heard of Salem, but also I was kind of thinking, you know, H.P. Lovecraft, the great horror writer, with this idea that in seemingly innocent New England towns, terrible, demonic terrors wait and lurk. And if you go to those graveyards at Marblehead or places like that, there is something distinctively chilling about them. Do you not think? Is it the contrast?
回到欧洲，猎巫狂热正席卷德国、东盎格利亚和各种地方。我认为有趣的是，至少在英语世界的想象中，新英格兰有着特殊的共鸣。所以每个人都听说过塞勒姆（Salem），而且我也在想，比如伟大的恐怖小说家H.P.洛夫克拉夫特（H.P. Lovecraft）有一个观点：在看似纯真无邪的新英格兰小镇里，可怕的恶魔恐怖正在等待和潜伏着。如果你去马布尔黑德（Marblehead）或类似地方的那些墓园，它们确实有一种独特的阴森感。你不觉得吗？是这种对比吗？
Yes, the contrast, isn't it, between the idealism and the dream of the shining city on a hill, the imagined godly community, and then the monsters lurking within. The monsters are not, I mean, obviously, they were embattled in New England. They thought themselves embattled by the Dutch or by the French or by the Native Americans, by the Indians, as they would have called them. But the monsters are within. That's the fascinating thing. The monster is your neighbour, right? But isn't it also the fact that this is the beginning and these are towns that are literally perched on the edge of a vast, vast swathes of land that for the English settlers, they know nothing about it. And that is, I mean, anyone who's been lost in a wood
是的，正是这种对比，不是吗？山巅之城的光辉理想与梦想、想象中的神圣社区，与潜伏在其中的怪物之间的对比。这些怪物并非……显而易见，他们在当时的新英格兰四面楚歌。他们认为自己受到了荷兰人、法国人或美洲原住民（即他们所谓的印第安人）的围困。但怪物就在内部。这才是最迷人的地方。怪物就是你的邻居，对吧？但这也是因为这是一个开端，这些小镇字面意义上就建立在广袤无垠的土地边缘，而对于英国定居者来说，他们对这片土地一无所知。这意味着，任何在树林里迷过路的人
knows that that is a state in which you are more prone to imagine. That's right. Witchcraft and ghosts and demons. Dominic, do we have someone who can talk about this with much greater expertise than we can? Much greater expertise, Tom. Yes, absolutely. We have Malcolm Gaskell, Professor Malcolm Gaskell.
都知道，在这种状态下，你更容易浮想联翩。没错。巫术、鬼魂和恶魔。多米尼克，我们有没有人能以比我们更专业的知识来谈论这个话题？专业知识丰富得多，汤姆。是的，当然。我们有马尔科姆·加斯凯尔（Malcolm Gaskell）教授，马尔科姆·加斯凯尔教授。
He's the Emeritus Professor at the University of East Anglia in Britain. And his book, The Ruin of All Witches. So that story that I start with is the way Malcolm starts his book. Malcolm, welcome to The Rest is History. Thank you so much for coming on the show. Thanks for having me. Glad to be here. So Malcolm, for the benefits of listeners not familiar with this period, we are in the
他是英国东盎格利亚大学的名誉教授。他的书是《所有女巫的毁灭》（The Ruin of All Witches）。我开场讲的那个故事，就是马尔科姆书中的开篇方式。马尔科姆，欢迎来到《历史的余烬》。非常感谢你来到节目中。谢谢邀请我来。很高兴来到这里。那么马尔科姆，为了让不熟悉这段时期的听众了解情况，我们正处于
17th century. We're in the sort of 1640s, 1650s, and New England. So why is there a New England at all? Well, in the first half of the 17th century, there are huge migrations to colonial America. And there's been settlements in Virginia early in the 17th century, the Mayflower goes over in 1620. But it's not really until the 1630s that you get tens of thousands of people going from england over there and there's a whole stack of reasons why they go the religious reasons and political reasons and economic reasons um people in new england
17世纪。我们正身处新英格兰的1640年代、1650年代左右。那么，为什么会出现新英格兰这样一个地方呢？嗯，在17世纪的上半叶，有大量人口移民到美洲殖民地。17世纪初弗吉尼亚就已经有了定居点，“五月花号”于1620年渡过大西洋。但直到1630年代，才有成千上万的人从英国去到那里，他们去的原因有一大堆：宗教原因、政治原因和经济原因。嗯，新英格兰的人们
the clues in the name they want to kind of make a new england for themselves they want to improve conditions for themselves but they also want to set an example to the old country where they feel it's lost its way in all sorts of things like charity and piety and so on. So Malcolm, the famous expression of that desire to set an example is John Winthrop, who in 1630, as he's sailing out to America, preaches a sermon in which he refers to his ambition to make New England like a city on a hill, a kind of shining example. And going with John Winthrop is a man called William Pynchon, who is much less well known. Could you just tell us a bit about him and why specifically he goes? Because he's a kind of, he's in your book and he's kind of very representative figure in many ways.
顾名思义，他们想为自己建立一个新的英格兰，他们想改善自己的生活条件，但他们也想为故国树立一个榜样——在他们看来，故国在慈善、虔诚等方方面面都已经迷失了方向。所以马尔科姆，这种渴望树立榜样的著名表象就是约翰·温斯罗普（John Winthrop）。他在1630年乘船前往美洲时发表了一篇布道，其中提到他的雄心壮志，是要把新英格兰建成一座山巅之城，一个闪耀的榜样。与约翰·温斯罗普同行的还有一个人叫威廉·平钦（William Pynchon），他远没有那么知名。你能跟我们讲讲他以及他为什么要特地去那里吗？因为他在你的书里出现过，而且在许多方面他都是一个非常具有代表性的人物。
Yeah, it's an incredible early American life, really starts out in very obscure existence in a very small place called Springfield outside Chelmsford. And he's a sort of country church warden and, you know, minorry but really kind of nobody but he goes out to start a new life for himself and has this what turns out to be an extraordinary adventure and this is because he like so many people feels that so he's going out in the reign of charles the first as lots of people are and it's because they think that charles the first is a sort of crypto papist yeah who is introducing catholicism by the back door and flummery and churches and you know altars and whatever that sort of stereotype so i you know i think tom and i are great um ladybird aficionados so that sort of stereotype you know there was a there was a
是的，这确实是一段极其早期美洲生活。他最初在一个非常偏僻的小地方过着默默无闻的生活，那个小地方叫斯普林菲尔德（Springfield），在切姆斯福德（Chelmsford）外面。他有点像乡村教堂的司事，你知道的，是个无名小卒，但他出发去为自己开辟新生活，并迎来了这段后来证明是非凡的冒险。这是因为他和许多人一样，觉得……所以他是在查理一世统治时期出发的，就像许多人一样，这是因为他们认为查理一世有点像隐秘的天主教徒，
ladybird book so these were children's books for their our overseas listeners yeah um of the sort of these sort of very starchy Puritans, the Pilgrim Fathers and Plymouth Rock and all that sort of stuff. So that sort of holds up, does it? So if you'd gone out, they're all godly and they're all chatting about the Bible and there's this kind of austerity to them. Is that right?
嗯，通过后门引入天主教、各种繁文缛节、教堂还有祭坛等等诸如此类的刻板印象——所以，我认为汤姆和我都是“瓢虫书”（Ladybird）的狂热爱好者，那种刻板印象，你知道的，有一本
Some people are more godly than others. Some people just go out for economic reasons. I mean, people like John Winthrop and William Pynchon, you know, they've got an eye on the main prize. They're entrepreneurs. Everybody's obsessed with land from the start, but you can be interested in that and also be godly. In fact, they feel that that's part of God's plan for them, that they will go out and prosper. They are sort of conflicting ideals in some ways, or they turn out to be, but they don't think that they are. They think that those things are actually compatible and actually sort of mutually reinforcing, I guess. So that kind of Puritan
瓢虫书——这些是给儿童看的书，致我们的海外听众——讲述了那种非常刻板的清教徒、朝圣先父（Pilgrim Fathers）和普利茅斯石（Plymouth Rock）以及所有这些东西。所以那种形象确实存在，对吧？如果你去过那里，他们都是虔诚的，都在谈论圣经，他们有一种苦行僧般的简朴。是这样吗？
stereotype does exist, but it's not everybody and it's not everyone through and through. So the religious aspect of it, for the Puritans, there is this idea, you know, that founding the city on the hill, it's this idea that it will be a community of saints. So how do you qualify as a saint? How do you know that you're a saint? What do you do with people who aren't saints? Well, the godly people that go over there, they're already convinced because they've already set their faces against, as Dominic said, this kind of, you know, this kind of crypto-popery, as they see in the church and government of Charles I. But when they go over to these communities, they have to kind of reprove themselves, because there, a church isn't just, you know, isn't just like a parish
有些人比其他人更虔诚。有些人去那里纯粹是出于经济原因。我的意思是，像约翰·温斯罗普和威廉·平钦这样的人，你知道的，他们眼里盯着最大的奖品。他们是企业家。从一开始，每个人都对土地着迷，但你既可以对土地感兴趣，也可以很虔诚。事实上，他们觉得这是上帝为他们规划的一部分，他们将走出去并走向繁荣。在某些方面，这些是相互冲突的理想，或者说后来证明是冲突的，但他们自己并不这么认为。他们认为这些事情实际上是相容的，而且实际上是相互促进的，我想是的。所以这种清教徒
church in England for all comers, good and bad. There, they've set themselves up as a separate congregation, where in order to be part of that covenant as they see it you have to actually demonstrate that the holy spirit has entered you and you are a member of god's elect and that's a real problem for a lot of people it causes huge disappointment and even you know suicidal thoughts of total wretchedness and lack of self-worth because they feel that maybe actually they weren't elect after all it's something that you have to persuade yourself in your own heart. And if you're not elect, then you are doomed to perdition. Yeah.
的刻板印象确实存在，但并非所有人都是这样，也不是所有人从头到尾都如此。所以其中的宗教方面，对于清教徒来说，有这样一种观点：建立山巅之城，这个想法意味着它将是一个圣徒的社区。那么，你如何获得圣徒的资格？你怎么知道自己是圣徒？你如何对待那些不是圣徒的人？嗯，那些去那里的虔诚之人，他们已经坚信不疑了，因为正如多米尼克所说，他们已经表明了自己的立场，反对这种在查理一世的教会和政府中看到的“隐秘的天主教倾向”。但当他们去到这些社区时，他们必须证明自己，因为在那里，教堂不仅仅是
And so the thing about Calvinism is it's, I mean, there are different strains and different interpretations of Calvinism, but essentially it's the idea that there is that from birth, before birth, there are the drowned and the saved. And so really it's about demonstrating to yourself and your community that you're on the side of the angels and you're not this sort of not wicked necessarily but this sort of you know the the light hasn't been switched on inside you you're a kind of a dark and essentially spiritually worthless person so this is pretty tough to come to terms with in their yeah you know in their culture and mentality.
英格兰那种面向所有人的好坏不分普通教区教堂。在那里，他们将自己建立为一个独立的会众，为了成为他们所认为的圣约的一部分，你必须实际证明圣灵已经进入了你，你是上帝的选民。这对很多人来说是个真正的问题，会导致巨大的失望，甚至（你知道的）产生一种彻底痛苦和缺乏自我价值的自杀倾向，因为他们觉得也许自己其实根本不是选民。这是你必须在自己内心说服自己的事情。如果你不是选民，那么你就注定要下地狱。是的。
So the stakes are very high, aren't they? Because you're not just building a new life economically. You're not just building a house and trying to get food and chisel out, carve out this new life in what appears to be a wilderness. They talk of it as a wilderness. Obviously, there are, as you said, Native Americans. You're surrounded by enemies. But I was going to say, is it that that causes, that drives the witch craze? But
加尔文主义的特点是——虽然加尔文主义有不同的流派和不同的解释，但本质上它是这样一种观点：从出生起，甚至在出生之前，就已经有了沉沦者和得救者。所以实际上，这关乎向你自己和你的社区证明你站在天使这一边，你不是那种——未必是邪恶，而是那种——内在的光芒没有被点亮的人，你是一个黑暗的、本质上在精神上毫无价值的人。因此，在他们的文化和心态中，要接受这一点是相当艰难的。
of course, they're taking the witch craze with them to some extent, aren't they? Because as Tom said, there are witch crazes in Europe in this period. So for the benefit of people who don't know anything about it, like me, why are people getting all hot under the collar about witches in the 17th century in Europe before they even get to America? Well, the witch craze is, I mean, there are lots of factors. I mean, there's no time to talk about in any sort of detail, but to have a witch craze, you need lots of factors to come together at the same time. It's economic and it's religious and it's political and it's cultural and it's legal. And you get all those things together, you can have a witch hunt. This is a very polarised
所以赌注非常高，对吧？因为你不仅在经济上建立新生活。你不仅是在建造房屋、试图获取食物，并在看似荒野的地方开辟出这样一种新生活。他们称之为荒野。显而易见，正如你所说，这里有美洲原住民。你被敌人包围了。但我要说的是，是这导致了、驱动了猎巫狂热吗？但是
mentality where they feel that there is this battle for the soul of Europe from the 16th century into the 17th century, a kind of long reformation where Catholicism has been pushed out of many states and Protestantism has taken over. But that's not a, you know, that's not a happy, healthy transition that creates religious wars, creates intense religious conflict about really what the shape of Europe should be, and in fact, the whole of the Western world. And it's part of that tension and that disagreement, a kind of collective anxiety about what the world should be and what God's intentions are, that divides people from the side of God to the side of the devil. It's just a very sort of polarized, bipolar way of looking at oneself and the whole of the devil. It's just a very sort of polarized, bipolar way of looking
当然，他们在某种程度上把猎巫狂热也带了过去，对吧？因为正如汤姆所说，这一时期的欧洲也存在猎巫狂热。所以，为了让那些对一无所知的人（比如我）了解情况，为什么17世纪欧洲人在还没去美洲之前，人们就会对女巫狂热起来呢？嗯，猎巫狂热的原因有很多。我的意思是，没有时间详细讨论，但要引发猎巫狂热，你需要许多因素在同一时间汇聚在一起。它是经济的、宗教的、政治的、文化的和法律的。当所有这些因素汇聚在一起时，你就会引发一场猎巫行动。这是一种高度极化的
at oneself and the whole of the world out there. And those people that fall foul of it are potentially wicked. So the witch stands in for the extreme form of the negative ideal of what individuals and the nation should be. So the witch is your neighbor, right? The witch is somebody almost always that is very close to you, or living in close proximity, let's say, and is an outsider in your community, or is a rival, or both of those things. Witchcraft exists in people's minds in different ways. So there's a kind of idealized form of the witch.
心态，他们觉得从16世纪到17世纪，有一场争夺欧洲灵魂的战斗，这是一场漫长的宗教改革，天主教被许多国家排挤出去，新教取而代之。但这并不是一个（你知道的）快乐、健康的过渡，它引发了宗教战争，引发了关于欧洲（乃至整个西方世界）究竟应该是什么样子的激烈宗教冲突。正是这种紧张局势和分歧的一部分——一种关于世界应该是什么样子以及上帝意图是什么的集体焦虑——将人们从上帝的一边分化到了魔鬼的一边。这是一种非常极化的、非黑即白的看待自己以及整个世界的方式。那些陷入其中的人潜在地就是邪恶的。因此，女巫取代了个人和国家应当具有的负面理想的极端形式。所以，女巫就是你的邻居，对吧？女巫几乎总是那些离你非常近、或者说紧邻而居的人，同时又是你社区里的外来者，或者是竞争对手，或者兼而有之。巫术在人们脑海中以不同的方式存在。所以有一种理想化的女巫形式，
There's almost a sort of fantasy witch of the devil worshiper who gathers with other witches on the hillside at midnight. Everyone kind of has that in their mind. But when it comes to making accusations, those sort of people are not apparent. So that it is actually the witch becomes manifested, as you say, in someone that's often very close to you, not so much an outsider, but someone actually, ironically, where proximity is the problem rather than distance. But it's somebody who falls foul of expectations of the way people are supposed to behave within the community. And that doesn't mean to say that everybody who falls
几乎有一种魔鬼崇拜者的幻想女巫——她们在午夜时分与其他女巫聚集在山坡上。每个人脑子里都有这种印象。但当进行指控时，那种人却并不显现。因此，女巫实际上表现为——正如你所说——一个通常离你非常近的人，与其说是个外来者，不如说恰恰相反，具有讽刺意味的是，彼此贴得太近反而是个问题，而不是距离远。但这是一个未能达到社区内人们预期行为标准的人。这并不是说所有未能达到这一点的人都会受到指控，但这是前提条件。这是一个没有完全参与其中、循规蹈矩的人，部分原因（可能是）因为他们依赖他人，可能因为他们脾气暴躁，但这是一个没有真正顺应你们那个往往充满焦虑、紧张、经济困窘的社区里随波逐流、追求同质化和常态的人。没错。因为马尔科姆，这才是关键，对吧？所以在新英格兰，很显然你可以看到，仅仅因为生活在广袤蔓延的荒野中那一个个高度孤立的社区里，人们对光明与黑暗、上帝与魔鬼、义人与非义人的焦虑就会受到极大的加剧。但还有一个你刚才暗示过的物质因素，那就是人们去那里不仅仅是为了宗教原因，也是为了经济原因。生活很艰难。这里有发大财的机会，但在这场竞争的意识中也注定会有失败者。这也成了人们怀疑他人施展巫术的一个重要部分，对吧？人们在利用恶毒的手段、超自然的手段来陷害别人。是的，绝对是这样。我的意思是，我们应该记住，实际上这些在1630年代带着他们的妖魔化观念前往那里的清教徒，巫术指控开始出现其实花了相当长的时间。并不是他们刚一抵达，
foul of that is accused, but that's the precondition. It's somebody who isn't quite playing the game, partly, you know, possibly because that they are dependent, possibly because they are cantankerous, but it's somebody who's not actually just swimming in the stream of, you know, conformity and normality within your often rather anxious, fraught, you know, economically imperiled community. Right. Because Malcolm, that's the key, isn't it? So in New England, obviously you can see that anxieties about light and dark, God and the devil, the justified and the unjustified, would be incredibly harmed simply by virtue of being in very isolated communities amid a kind
你知道的，戴着高筒帽、穿着搭扣鞋，就开始指责身边的女巫。
of vast spreading wilderness. But there is also this material element that you hinted at there, that people are going out there, not just for religious reasons, but for economic reasons. And it's tough. And there are great fortunes to be made, but also there are bound to be losers in this sense of competition. And that becomes an important part in kind of why people suspect others of witchcraft as well isn't it it's it's people are employing malign means supernatural means to do other people down yeah that's definitely it i mean we should remember that actually these these puritans that go over in the 1630s with their demonic ideas it takes quite a long time for witchcraft accusations to start happening isn't that as soon as they arrive uh you know in in their stovepipe hats and buckle shoes, they start pointing the finger at witches
拿起草叉。是的，完全如此。这花了一代人的时间才发生，因为需要一代人的时间，那些永远是巫术指控背后推动力的经济压力才能真正发挥作用。因此，新英格兰虽然有所有这些处女地，但这些社区确实很快就填满了。然后人们不得不离开并建立自己的卫星社区。所以这些压力很快就被制造出来了。所以马尔科姆，回到我们一直在谈论的威廉·平钦身上，他是和约翰·温斯罗普一起乘船出发的。他是一个非常虔诚的基督徒。他对神学着迷，所有这些事情。但他基本上也是一个锐意进取的资本家。他——我说的对吗？——开始投资毛皮贸易，比如海狸捕猎和所有这些东西。他发现新英格兰海岸沿线的海狸已经开始消失。于是他决定深入内陆。他建立的定居点被他以老家英国的地名命名为斯普林菲尔德（Springfield），这不是一个宗教定居点。这是一个以赚钱为目的建立的定居点。是这样吗？是的。我的意思是，它是宗教性的。他们很虔诚，但建立它并不是出于这个首要意图。而东部的许多社区都是移植过来的虔诚会众，这确实（你知道的）是他们DNA里从一开始就有的东西。但平钦呢，他是一个企业家，他是一个（你知道的）人们可以认出的
all around them. Getting out of the pitchfork. Yeah, quite. It takes a generation for that to happen because it takes a generation for the kind of economic pressures which are always behind witchcraft accusations to really get going. And so that New England, there is all this virgin territory, but these communities do get full up quite quickly. And then people have to go off and form their own kind of satellites from that. So that those pressures are, you know, created quite quickly. So Malcolm, just to return to William Pynchon, who we were talking about, he sailed out with John Winthrop. He is a very devout Christian. He is fascinated by theology, all that kind of stuff. But he is also basically a go-getting capitalist. And he is, am I right,
现代资本主义企业家。所以他甚至在英国时就从事毛皮贸易，但他去（原话为去参加派对，此处结合语境修正为去目的地）是因为他想离货源更近。然后他实际上从马萨诸塞州搬到了康涅狄格河谷，因为他想尽可能靠近那些来自美洲原住民的、日益减少的海狸皮贸易。所以这才是他真正在做的事情。他试图尽可能多地捞钱。但是，（你知道的）这在他脑海中与他的虔诚理想并不冲突。他觉得这是上帝对天意的计划的一部分，对他和其他像他的人来说都是如此。于是他建立了斯普林菲尔德这个镇，他以自己在埃塞克斯郡的斯普林菲尔德命名，
that he starts to invest in the fur trade, so beaver trapping and all that kind of stuff. And he finds that already along the New England seaboard, the beaver are starting to vanish. And so he decides to go inland. And the settlement that he founds, which he called Springfield after the place that he came from in England, this is not a religious settlement. This is a settlement founded with the aim of making money. Is that right? Yeah. I mean, it is religious. They are godly, but it's not founded with that primary intention in mind. Whereas so many of those communities on the uh towards the east are transplanted godly congregations that's really you know that's their um that's in their dna right from the start but pension yeah he's an entrepreneur he's a kind of you know one can recognize him as
那是他曾经来的地方。我从你的书中得到的印象是，这有点像资本家的结合，正如你和汤姆所说的那样，但它也稍微带有一点庄园领主的色彩。所以基本上所有人都欠他钱，更受制于他。他们必须用实物向他支付。他一开始是怎么把他们吸引到那里去的？他是……消息是否在波士顿等地的会众中传开？
a modern capitalist entrepreneur so he's working in the fur trade even when he's in england but he goes to doing the party because he wants to be closer to the source. And then he actually goes from Massachusetts to the Connecticut Valley because he wants to get as close as possible to the increasingly dwindling trade in beaver fur that's coming down from Native Americans. So that's really what he's doing. He's trying to cash in as much as he possibly can. But, you know, that's not in his mind in conflict with his godly ideals. He feels that's part of God's providential plan for him and others like him. So he establishes this town, Springfield, which he names after Springfield in Essex,
哦，这个叫平钦的人正在建立一个新的社区。你知道，你为什么不一起来呢？他有工作给你，或者说这些人是他认识的，他是怎么让人们加入他的？嗯，基本上我们忘了，实际上这些人（你知道的）非常偏远，他们确实觉得离家很远——英国远在三千英里之外。但他们实际上联系非常紧密，他们的通信其实相当不错，只是比我们（你知道的）今天发生的速度要慢。所以当平钦需要什么东西时，他会发出信件。他到处都有人脉，这里那里都有熟人。所以他会写信，或者他会亲自回去，如果他需要（你知道的）——如果斯普林菲尔德需要木桶，他就会去某个地方雇佣一个
where he'd come from. And I get the impression from your book that there's a slight sort of, it's a combination of the capitalist, as you and Tom were saying, but it's also a slight Lord of the Manor side to it. So basically everybody's in debt to him, more in hock to him. They have to pay him in kind. How does he attract them there in the first place? Does he sort of, does the word go out among the congregations in Boston and places like that?
制桶匠；如果需要一个牧师（正如他所做的那样），他就会去雇一个牧师，乔治·莫克森（George Moxon）。所以他所做的是重现这种他在英国熟悉的、相当复杂且整合良好的社区。事实上，（你知道的）当你移民到新英格兰时，你会发现所有你怀念的东西。你知道，这些都是人们写信回来说的东西：哦，我忘了带肥皂、钉子，因为你不能直接出门去买。而在英国当然有商店。是的。（你知道的）你可以去买东西。但这正是平钦所做的。而且正如你所说，他有点像庄园领主。这里总是有一种（你知道的）历史的讽刺意味，那就是（你知道的）这看起来非常进步、非常激进、非常有远见，但它也是一个非常恋旧的企业。所以实际上在美洲，平钦确实成为了现代资本主义企业家，但正如你所说，他也成为了一个非常老派的庄园领主，控制着一切，每个人都对她俯首帖耳，他向下施恩。对她和其他类似的人来说，这太棒了。因此，正如平钦建立这个地方部分是因为他虔诚，但主要是因为他想赚钱一样，想必那些定居者也是这种混合的情感和动机。人们既想成为虔诚社区的一部分，但也想发财。
Oh, this guy Pynchon is starting a new community. You know, why don't you come along? He's got work for for you or is it people that he knows or how does he get people to join him well essentially we forget that actually that these people are you know very remote and they do feel that they're a long way from home which is England 3,000 miles away and but they're actually very well connected their communications are really not bad they're just slower than we would you know it happened today so so the pension when he needs something he sends letters out he's got contacts all over the place fingers in pies here there and everywhere and so that he will write letters or he will travel back and um if he needs you know if springfield needs barrels he will go and hire a
他们想要土地。他们想要组建家庭。是的，我的意思是，土地是最关键的东西。土地贯穿了整个故事。当然，它也贯穿了从16世纪末到17世纪上半叶英国的故事。在英国，土地不够。劳动力太多。在美洲，劳动力不够。土地太多。在美洲，土地有的是，劳动力不够。
cooper somewhere and if it needs a minister that as he does, then he goes and hires a minister, George Moxon. So what he's doing is recreating this rather sophisticated, integrated community that he knows from England. In fact, you know, one of the things that you find when you emigrate to New England is all the things that you miss. You know, they're all the things that people write back and say, oh, I forgot to bring this soap, nails, because you can't just go out and buy it. Whereas, of course, in England has shops. Yeah. You know, you can actually go and buy stuff. But so that this is what Pynchon does. And he is, as you say, a kind of lord of the manor. There's always this, you know, one of the historical ironies of this is that, you know, it seems very progressive and very radical, very forward looking, but it's also a very
所以实际上，他们重新平衡了事情，然后新英格兰变得很像英国。所以这就是土地……有投机者想要大片大片的处女地，就像他们在英国排干沼泽地时所做的那样，例如。这种同类投机。但这也是一件非常私人的事情，而且相当普通的人想要另一块田地（你知道的），或者他们想要一块更大的田地，或者他们想要一块草地，或者他们想要进入树林的权利等等。所以这是从社会的最顶层到底层，
nostalgic enterprise. And so that actually out in America, Pynchon does get to be the modern capitalist entrepreneur, but he also gets to be a very old fashioned lord of the manor, as you say, who controls everything and everybody owes him deference and he passes patronage downwards. And for him and others like him, that's great. And so just as Pynchon is founding this partly because he's godly, but mainly because he wants to make money, presumably the settlers, it's the same kind of mixture of emotions and motives. People want to be part of a godly community, but they also want to become rich.
获取土地不仅因为土地就是金钱，土地也是权力和权威。是的，这是一个古老得不能再古老的故事了。所以让我们把故事中的两个主要主角带进来，你在你的书《所有女巫的毁灭》中对他们进行了如此精彩的讲述。所以其中一个（嗯）是一个威尔士女佣，她的名字叫玛丽·刘易斯（Mary Lewis）。我认为公平地说，她在威尔士老家的生活相当糟糕，对吧？所以给我们讲讲她，以及她为什么要来到平钦的镇子。玛丽·刘易斯在蒙茅斯郡（Monmouthshire）结了婚。结果她的丈夫是个混蛋。在一个毕竟是新教的国家里，他却是个天主教徒。
They wanted to get land. They want to set up families. Yeah, I mean, land is the key thing. Land runs right through this story. And of course, it runs right through the story of England from the late 16th into the first half of the 17th century. In England, there's not enough of it. There's too much labor. In America, there's not enough of it. There's too much labour. In America, there's loads of it and not enough labour.
那是个混蛋。而且，他确实是个混蛋，但也极其糟糕。他虐待她，抛弃了她，并且（你知道的）抱歉，他欺凌她，然后抛弃了她。所以（你知道的）她的生活中存在着这种精神和情感上的空白。她只是觉得，正如我认为许多（你知道的）潜在移民所感受到的那样，那里已经没有什么值得她留恋的了。她加入了威尔士这个相当具有个人魅力、激进的新教社群。所以她已经在为自己可能会去新英格兰的那种世界做好了准备。
So actually, they rebalance things and then New England becomes rather like England. So it's this land... There are speculators who want great, vast areas of virgin territory as, of course, they do in England when they drain the fens, for example. This same kind of speculation. But it's also a very personal thing and really quite ordinary people want another field you know or they want a bigger field or they want a bit of meadow or they want access to a woodlot and so on and so this is right from the top to the bottom of society
当然，其他人也在去。所以时机到了，她可以（你知道的）上一艘船，然后离开，彻底重新开始。所以马尔科姆，在这个教派中，而且想必去到美洲，她非常非常清楚地意识到那些得救者与未得救者之间的划分，那些赢得光明的人与那些面临沉沦威胁的人之间的划分。是的，她是。我认为像许多人一样，她可能没想到自己必须
and getting hold of land because land isn't just money land is also power and authority yeah and this is a story as old as the hills so let's bring in two of the main players in this story that you tell so brilliantly in your book uh the ruin of all witches so so one of them um is a welsh maid servant and her name is mary lewis and she had, I think it's fair to say, a pretty awful life back home in Wales, hasn't she? So tell us about her and why she's come over to Pynchon's town. Mary Lewis, back in Monmouthshire, she gets married. Her husband turns out to be a wrongan. He's a Catholic in what is, after all, a Protestant country.
证明自己，因为当然，那些在英国和威尔士、自认为是精英阶层的人，在这方面对自己非常有信心。所以（你知道的）在英国和威尔士、自认为是精英阶层的人，在这方面对自己非常有信心。所以（你知道的）她将以一种全新方式接受考验。我的意思是，每个人都要在物质上和精神上接受考验。这就是让这段经历如此艰难的原因之一。所以她并不是——她有点知道自己（你知道的）要面对什么，但我认为没有人真正为这给他们个人带来的挑战做好准备。她最终是如何具体来到斯普林菲尔德的？她是从一开始就计划去
That is a wrongan. And that is, he is a real, but he's also horrible as well. And he abuses her and he deserts her and he, you know, he, sorry, bullies her, then he deserts her. And so, you know, there's this kind of spiritual and emotional void in her life. She just feels, as I think many, you know, potential migrants do, that there's nothing left for her there. And she joins this rather kind of charismatic, you know, radical Protestant community in Wales. So she's already kind of being set up for the kind of world that she might go to in New England.
那里，还是只是到了那里然后四处张望？不，她被雇为女佣，通过谁需要劳动力的“森林电报”（口耳相传），威廉·平钦雇佣她去给他女儿当女佣，他女儿有年幼的孩子，又怀孕了，正需要有人帮忙做家务。这正是她最终完成从马萨诸塞州东海岸到康涅狄格河谷斯普林菲尔德那一百英里旅程的原因。对于像玛丽这样的人来说，为了描绘这幅画面，当她到达斯普林菲尔德时，她是否会想——哦，这真是——显然我们不知道她在想什么——但她是否会想
Of course, others are going too. And so the time comes that it's, you know, she can get on a boat and go and completely start over. And so Malcolm, in this sect, and presumably going to America, she is very, very conscious of this division between those who are saved and those who aren't, between those who have won the light and those who are threatened with perdition. Yeah, she is. I think that like many, she probably doesn't expect that she's going to have to prove
哦，这真是——显然我们不知道她在想什么——但她是否会想，这就像家一样（你知道的），这是对家的重现，还是说它显然是一个更加焦虑、困难、黑暗的地方？你会怎么说？我认为这是一个混合体。我的意思是（你知道的）每个人都在试图寻找熟悉的东西，重现熟悉的东西，因为理所当然，这就是我们所做的。（你知道的）那是令人感到慰藉的。那是你所熟悉的世界。但这只是——那只是一项艰苦的工作。而且因为他们非常清楚那里有狼（家里没有狼），有美洲原住民（家里没有美洲原住民），（你知道的）他们之间存在敌意。物资短缺。还有流行病。
herself because of course, those who, you know, in England and in Wales, who believe themselves to be part of the elite, they're very sure of themselves in that regard. And so, you know, in England and in Wales, who believe themselves to be part of the elite, they're very sure of themselves in that regard. And so, you know, she's going to be tested in a totally new way. I mean, everyone is tested materially and spiritually. That's one of the things that makes this experience so tough. So she doesn't, she sort of knows what she's, you know, she's in for, but I don't think anybody is quite prepared for the challenges that that makes on them personally. And how does she end up in Springfield specifically? Is she planning to go
还有（正如他们所看到的）那片广袤的荒野，他们根本不知道外面潜伏着什么。我认为每个人都感到了这种生存威胁。所以英国在1640和50年代当然有它的问题，但没有人会相信英国会不复存在。他们不知道它会走向何方，但它不会被从地图上抹去。但他们对新英格兰的看法却是这样的。他们知道实际上最后这个实验可能会失败，他们要么得回家，要么就会死。特别是对玛丽而言，事实是她结婚了。
there from the beginning or does she just get to do it and then look around? No, she gets hired as a maid servant and through the kind of bush telegraph of who needs labour and so on, that William Pynchon hires her to be a maid servant to his daughter, who has got young children and is pregnant again, and is just going to need help around the house. And that's really how she ends up making that 100-mile journey from the eastern seaboard of Massachusetts over to the Connecticut Valley, where Springfield is. And then for someone like Mary, just to sort of paint the picture, when she gets to Springfield, does she sort of think, oh, this is, I mean, obviously we don't know what she thinks, but does she sort of think oh this is I mean obviously we don't know what she thinks but does she does she sort of think this is just like home you know this is a
她在英国抛弃了虐待她的丈夫。她现在是一名女佣，周围都是孩子。她仅仅是她为其工作的女主人的家庭的一个附属品。但想必她也想要一个家庭。她想要自己的独立。这太可怕了，如果你是一个老处女，你会被嘲笑为“刺背鱼”（thornback）。她不想当老处女，她在寻找潜在的丈夫。不，她——我的意思是，就像几乎其他人一样——她想要顺从。在这个世界里，顺从意味着（呃）结婚并拥有自己的孩子，拥有自己独立的家庭。这对男女都适用，所有年轻人想要组建自己的家庭，这就是为什么在英国生活如此艰难，因为你需要土地、需要工作，所以他们经常去美洲，并不是为了寻找财富。
recreation of home or is it obviously a more anxious difficult darker kind of place would you say I think it's a mixture I mean that, you know, everyone's trying to seek out the familiar, to recreate the familiar, because of course, that's what we do. You know, that's what's comforting. That's the world that you know. But it's just, that is just hard work. And because they're very conscious of the fact that there are wolves there, no wolves at home, there are Native Americans, no Native Americans at home, that, you know, there was hostility with them. There were shortages of things. There's epidemic disease.
我认为这是一种非常现代的看法。但他们确实希望建立一个独立的家庭，以及他们自己的微型政治和经济单位，因为在早期现代世界中，家庭就是这样的单位。所以，是的，她基本上想抹去她的过去。她想忘记她的丈夫。她想让婚姻无效，她想找一个新丈夫，（呃）并且只是——我想只是在这个世界上做个正常人。然后，正如运气所愿，她的目光落在了完美的人身上。
And just this, you know, this wilderness beyond, as they see it, they just don't really know what lies out there. And I think everybody feels this existential threat. So that England, of course, has its problems in the 1640s and 50s, but nobody ever believes that England will cease to exist. They don't know where it's going, but it won't be wiped off the map. But that's how they feel about New England. They know that actually in the end, this experiment could fail and they'll all either have to go home or they'll die. And for Mary specifically, there's the fact that she's married.
所以他是休·帕森斯（Hugh Parsons），一个被带进来做砖的人——是的，他们需要砖，他们买不起——她认为他是个非常棒的小伙子。他是一个（呃）体格健壮——做砖是体力活——他是一个体格威猛的家伙，也许有点安静——正如我们将要发现的那样。但是，她的目光落在了他身上，他的故事是什么？我们对他的了解不多，对吧？他更……不，我们对他的了解要少得多，甚至不完全确定他来自哪里。当时在英国，叫休·帕森斯的竟然有大约20个左右，
She's left her abusive husband in England. She's now working as a maidservant, surrounded by children. And she's merely an appendage of the family, you know, of the mistress for whom she's working. But presumably she wants a family as well. She wants her independence. And this is terrible, that if you're a spinster, you were mocked as a thornback. She doesn't want to be a thornback she's looking for a potential husband no she i mean like almost everybody else she wants to conform and in this world conformity means uh getting married and having children of your own having your own separate household this is true for men and women all young people want to form their own household that's the that's why it's so hard in england because you need land you need work so they're
数量惊人。所以很难分辨。但他确实——当然他一定是个——我的意思是，他给人的感觉是一个（你知道的）身材高大、皮肤黝黑、神秘莫测的男子。
often going to america not to seek their fortunes. I think that's a very kind of modern way of looking at it. But they do want to form a separate family and their own little political as well as economic unit, because that's what in the early modern world, that's what the household is. So, yeah, she wants to basically erase her past. She wants to forget her husband. She wants the marriage to be annulled and she wants to find a new husband and just just i think just be normal in that world and then as luck would have it her eye falls on the perfect person so he is few parsons he's a guy that's been brought
我想也许——再次说明，这只是猜测——玛丽可能对他略有一点好奇，因为他确实非常安静。这是一个贯穿我们所知的关于他的一切的特征。他是一个寡言少语、情绪也极少的人。当然，这将在适当的时候给他带来麻烦。但是，（你知道的）她喜欢他，他也喜欢她。而且（你知道的）我认为这不是天作之合，我不太确定这算什么良缘，但他们打算在一起。所以她让自己的婚姻无效了，对吧？
in to make bricks yeah they need bricks they can't buy them and she thinks he's a very fine fellow he's a sort of physically to make making bricks hard work he's a physically impressive bloke he's perhaps a little bit quiet um as we'll discover but so her gaze falls on him and what's his story we don't know so much about him do we he's a bit more no we know much much less about him uh not even entirely sure where he comes from there are about 20 or so Hugh Parsons amazingly amazingly, in England at this time. So it's a bit hard to tell. But he is, yeah, certainly he must be, I mean, he comes across as a kind of, you know, kind of tall, dark, mysterious man.
是的。她去找平钦并得到了准许，因为她的丈夫抛弃了她。她在威尔士的天主教丈夫抛弃了她。所以她和休结婚了。起初这一切看起来都那么美好和粉红。他们在斯普林菲尔德开始了他们的新生活，这个新家庭。也许我们现在应该休息一下，因为我不想（你知道的）
I think that maybe, again, it's speculation, but Mary is possibly slightly intrigued by him because he is actually very quiet. And this is a characteristic that runs right through everything we know about him. He's a man of few words and also few emotions. And, of course, that will cause him problems in due course. But, yeah, you know, she likes him, he likes her. And, you know, I think that it's not a match made in heaven. I'm not quite sure where it's made, but they're going to get together. So she gets her marriage annulled, doesn't she?
对我们的听众剧透太多。这个故事将会发生相当黑暗的转变，汤姆，不是吗？确实如此。它并没有一个好结局。所以想知道发生了什么，请在休息后回来。获取加更节目和直播门票的优先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们正身处17世纪中叶的新英格兰，具体来说是在新建立的斯普林菲尔德镇，一对年轻夫妇休和玛丽·帕森斯在那里安了家。玛丽接连生了几个孩子。在这里为我们讲述这段婚姻以及斯普林菲尔德整个社区发生了什么的，是畅销书《所有女巫的毁灭》的作者马尔科姆·加斯凯尔。所以马尔科姆，这段婚姻结果如何？嗯，一开始还算顺利。我认为玛丽很快就怀孕了，她在1646年夏天生了一个孩子，他们俩都在努力工作，做着新英格兰家庭里人们做的事情：休在土地上辛苦劳作、做砖、砌烟囱，还为威廉·平钦做零工，这也是每个人都在做的事。而她在家里照顾孩子、做饭、打扫卫生，做这些事。我认为最初他们配合得很好。但是，当然，像所有的婚姻一样，你必须真正为之付出努力。
Yeah. She goes to pension and she gets permission because her husband has deserted her. Her Catholic husband back in Wales has deserted her. So she and Hugh get married. And at first it all looks lovely and rosy. They're starting this new life together, this new household in Springfield. And maybe we should take a break now because I don't want to, you know,
而在斯普林菲尔德，你必须付出（你知道的）百分之百甚至更多的努力。即便如此，你可能还是会弄砸。所以，巫术的威胁——把这个带入故事中——我的意思是，这普遍笼罩着整个社区，就像联盟中的所有社区一样。就像人们意识到巫术存在一样。你知道的，他们不认为这是迷信。他们知道外面存在着一个黑暗的世界。
get too deep into spoilers for our listeners. This story is going to take quite a dark turn, Tom, isn't it? It is. It doesn't end well. So to find out what happens, come back after the break. bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are in mid-17th century New England, specifically in the newly founded town of Springfield, where a young couple, Hugh and Mary Parsons, have set up house. Mary has a succession of children. And here to tell us about what happens
为了不给听众剧透太多。这个故事将会走向一个相当黑暗的方向，汤姆，对吧？是的。它没有一个好结局。所以想知道发生了什么，请在广告休息后回来。想要获得独家节目和现场门票的优先购买权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史其余部分》。我们正处于17世纪中叶的新英格兰，具体是在新建立的斯普林菲尔德镇，一对年轻夫妇休和玛丽·帕森斯在那里安了家。玛丽接连生了几个孩子。接下来为我们讲述
to that marriage and to the community of Springfield more generally, we have Malcolm Gaskell, author of the brilliant book, The Ruin of All Witches. So Malcolm, how does the marriage turn out? Well it starts off okay I think Mary is quite quickly becomes pregnant she has a baby in the summer of 1646 and they both work hard doing what people do in New England households so Hugh is out working on the land and making bricks and building chimneys and also doing jobs for William Pynchon, which is what everybody does. And she's at home looking after the baby and cooking and cleaning and doing that. It's, I think initially they get it right. But of course, like all marriages, you've got to really work at it.
这段婚姻以及斯普林菲尔德整个社区发生了什么的人，是《所有女巫的毁灭》一书的作者马尔科姆·加斯凯尔。那么马尔科姆，这段婚姻结果如何呢？嗯，一开始还算顺利，我认为。玛丽很快就怀孕了，她在1646年夏天生了一个孩子，他们两个人都辛勤工作，做着新英格兰家庭所做的事情：休在外劳作，耕地、做砖、砌烟囱，还为威廉·平昌做零工——这也是每个人都在做的事。而她在家里照顾孩子、做饭、打扫卫生。我认为最初他们做得不错。但当然，和所有婚姻一样，你必须真正用心经营它。
And in Springfield, you've got to work at it like, you know, 110%. And even then you might not get it right. So the threat of witchcraft, to bring that into the story, I mean, that hangs over the community generally, like all communities in the union. Like people are aware that witchcraft exists. You know, they don't see it as superstition. They know there's a dark world out there,
而在斯普林菲尔德，你必须付出百分之一百一十的努力去经营它。即便如此，你可能还是会弄砸。因此，将巫术的威胁引入故事中，我的意思是，这种阴影普遍笼罩着整个社区，就像美利坚的所有社区一样。人们意识到巫术是存在的。你知道，他们并不认为这是一种迷信。他们知道外面存在着一个黑暗的世界，
that the boundaries between the spiritual and the material are, you know, gossamer thin. And she is obsessed by witchcraft, isn't she, Mary? She becomes obsessed by it. Yeah, it mary she becomes obsessed but yeah it's very odd i mean it's interesting that the people everybody does know about witchcraft and misfortunes happen all the time and they feel the devil but it's very unusual for people to actually accuse others of witchcraft and it's true actually in england too but there you know springfield's been going for 15 years or more and there's no recorded accusations of witchcraft but that suddenly in
精神与物质之间的界限，你知道的，薄如蝉翼。玛丽对巫术着迷了，不是吗？她对巫术着迷了。是的，玛丽她着迷了，不过，是的，这非常奇怪，我的意思是，有趣的是，每个人都知道巫术和不幸的事情一直在发生，他们能感受到魔鬼的存在，但人们实际上去指控他人犯有巫术罪却非常罕见，这其实在英国也是如此，但你知道的，斯普林菲尔德已经存在了15年甚至更久，却没有关于巫术指控的记录，而突然在
around 1647 there are rumors of witchcraft which are coming from boston and up the connecticut valley it just seems to be taking hold you know it's just it's in the air before actually anybody points the finger and mary strangely does become really rather preoccupied by the idea that there are not just witches in, but that maybe there are witches coming from other communities. There's a woman arrives from the parish of Windsor down river called a widow called Mercy Marshfield. And Mary just gets into a head that she's, as she said, brought the devil with her. I mean, Malcolm, one of the things that really struck me reading your book, perhaps because my wife is a midwife,
大约1647年，出现了关于巫术的传言，这些传言来自波士顿和康涅狄格河谷，这似乎开始流行起来，你知道的，在任何人指责之前，这种情绪就已经在空气中弥漫了，而玛丽奇怪地变得非常全神贯注于这样一种想法：不仅这里有女巫，而且也许还有女巫来自其他社区。有一个女人从下游的风车镇教区来到这里，是一个名叫默西·马什菲尔德的寡妇。而玛丽心里认定她，正如她所说的，把魔鬼带在身边了。我的意思是，马尔colm，读你的书时真正让我震撼的一点，也许是因为我妻子是一名助产士，
was the degree to which the paranoia about witchcraft seems absolutely implicated with the process of childbirth and child rearing. In the book, you describe Margaret Jones, a midwife from Charleston, hanged in Boston in June 1648. News arrives from Dorchester of a devil disguised as a professed servant of Jesus Christ, who's another wicked midwife. Do you think that that is a kind of reflection of the way in which children are a focus both of kind of godliness, you know, a reward from God and the kind of the index of the potential that your family will have for future success. And therefore, if children are being attacked or children are somehow being malignly affected that's striking at the absolute heart both of the family and the community yeah and certainly in these these
在于人们对巫术的偏执似乎与生育和抚养孩子的整个过程密不可分。在书中，你描述了查尔斯顿的助产士玛格丽特·琼斯，她于1648年6月在波士顿被绞死。多切斯特传来了消息，说有一个伪装成耶稣基督虔诚仆人的魔鬼，那是另一个邪恶的助产士。你认为这是否在某种程度上反映了这样一种方式：孩子既是神圣的焦点（你知道的，来自上帝的奖赏），又是你的家庭未来成功潜力的指标。因此，如果孩子们遭到攻击，或者孩子们以某种方式受到恶意的伤害，那就是在打击家庭和社区的绝对核心，是的，而且肯定在这些
communities that your children are the future because they are you know that they're worried that they will actually die out they won't have a limited number of incomers from migration as you would have in england so they have to keep you, reproducing and passing on property and building wealth and so on. So, yeah, so there is that kind of pressure. But we should remember that there's an incredible emotional attachment to children, too. This is kind of myth that, you know, infant mortality is so high that you just have children. If they die, it's like, oh, well, we'll have another one and so on. But, you know, people are extreme.
社区里，孩子们就是未来，因为他们，你知道的，人们担心他们真的会消亡，他们不会像在英国那样有来自移民的源源不断的新来者，所以他们必须保持繁衍、传承财产、积累财富等等。所以，是的，确实有这种压力。但我们应该记住，对孩子们也有着不可思议的情感依恋。有一种神话认为，婴儿死亡率太高了，所以你只管生孩子。如果他们死了，那就，噢，没关系，我们再生一个，诸如此类。但是，你知道的，人们极其
People love their children and that they're incredibly distressed when they die and they don't really get used to it. So the children are often at the center of witchcraft accusations because of the anxiety that they cause their parents. And I think that, you know, here we can, you know, there's a bit more of a universal story, even if it's hard for us to identify with the strictly demonic side of their accusations. That seems very remote to us. But actually, if you think about the love that you feel for your children and how you'd feel if somebody threatened them,
人们深爱着他们的孩子，当孩子死去时，他们会感到无比痛苦，而且他们永远无法真正习惯这种事。因此，由于孩子们对父母造成的焦虑，他们往往成为巫术指控的核心。我认为，在这里我们可以，你知道的，有一个更具普遍性的故事，即使我们很难认同他们指控中严格的恶魔那一面。这在我们看来似乎非常遥远。但实际上，如果你想想你对孩子的爱，以及如果有人威胁他们你会作何感想，
especially something threatening them you couldn't naturally do anything about, I think then you get much closer to the idea of what witchcraft was in a community. I'm also struck by the fact that you mentioned that the mood changes or the mood darkens around 1647. So that must be a point at which they are getting news weeks or months late about the civil wars back home. Do you think that that plays a part in the sort of the darker turn, that people are suddenly aware,
特别是当面临你无能为力的某种威胁时，我认为那时你会更接近一个社区中巫术究竟是怎么回事的概念。我还注意到这样一个事实：你提到气氛在1647年左右发生了变化或变得阴暗。所以那一定是一个他们收到几周或几个月前的关于国内内战消息的时间点。你认为这是否在那种阴暗转变中发挥了作用，即人们突然意识到，
you know, there's a conflict that perhaps they fear will spread, maybe, to North America. I know they've left England because they want to start a new godly life, but a lot of them probably are quite conservative in some ways. The world is that classic thing of the world being turned upside down. So do you think that plays a part in it too, that there's a kind of political subject to all this? I do.
你知道的，发生了一场冲突，他们可能担心这场冲突会蔓延到北美。我知道他们离开英国是因为他们想开始一种崭新的虔诚生活，但他们中的许多人在某些方面可能相当保守。这个世界就是那种经典的世界颠倒的现象。所以你认为这也在其中发挥了作用吗，这一切背后有一种政治主题？我是这么认为的。
I think that they do feel the world turned upside down um across the atlantic there's this kind of um it's rather old-fashioned exceptionalist idea in certain kind of american historical writing that when you went to america you kind of forgot the old world because that's really why you'd gone and you start you started afresh and you you know you became this new authentic american self. But actually, these people call themselves the English. They've got English relatives. They sometimes go home to England. And that's very much where their hearts still lie. So that when England's torn apart by civil war and revolution, they feel it very, very intensely. They feel it on a spiritual level and they feel it at a personal level too, because they've got friends and family and they don't really know always what's happened to them. So this is a very interconnected world. They are
我认为他们确实感到了世界被颠倒了，嗯，在大西洋彼岸，在美国某些历史著作中有一种这样的小众的、嗯，相当老派的例外论观点：当你去到美国时，你有点忘记了旧世界，因为那正是你离开的真正原因，你重新开始，然后你，你知道的，变成了这个新的、真实的美国自我。但实际上，这些人自称是英国人。他们有英国亲戚。他们有时会回英国。这才是他们的心真正所在的地方。因此，当英国被内战和革命撕裂时，他们感受得非常非常强烈。他们在精神层面上感受到这一点，也在个人层面上感受到这一点，因为他们有朋友和家人，而且他们并不总是知道这些人发生了什么。所以这是一个高度互联的世界。他们
physically remote, but actually in their hearts, they kind of encompass the whole of the Western world. They worry about the future of Protestantism generally. That's what many Puritan divines do. They want to build this Protestant Western world and they feel that it's threatened. They feel that it's politically threatened and religiously threatened and that they're going to have to fight for it. So they're in Springfield, very much on the kind of the margins, the borders, the edges of New England, and they are getting disturbing political news from England, and they're getting these rumours of malevolent midwives killing children. And then you say that, like the plague, witchcraft was usually first encountered as news from distant parts. So there is that sense, rather like with an epidemic
身体上虽然偏远，但实际上在他们的心中，他们几乎包容了整个西方世界。他们担忧新教的整体未来。这是许多清教神学家所做的事情。他们想要建立这个西方新教世界，他们觉得它受到了威胁。他们觉得它在政治上和宗教上都受到了威胁，他们将不得不为之战斗。所以他们在斯普林菲尔德，非常处于新 England 的边缘、边境、边界地带，他们从英国得到了令人不安的政治新闻，他们听到了这些邪恶助产士杀害儿童的传言。然后你说，就像瘟疫一样，巫术通常首先是作为来自远方的消息被遭遇的。所以有那种感觉，非常像一场流行病
drawing closer to you, the sense that the threat of sorcery, the threat of witchcraft is approaching. How does it start to manifest itself in Springfield? Witchcraft kind of arrives in Springfield when Mary Parsons starts talking about it. You know, we haven't got a stereotypical view of the way that witchcraft accusations start. Sometimes something goes wrong, they don't like somebody, they get accused and then they get tried. But in Springfield, it's rather different. Mary Parsons starts suspecting somebody else, Mercy Marshfield, who then sues her for slander. And Mary started saying to her neighbours, you know, she bewitched your child,
离你越来越近，那种巫术的威胁、妖术的威胁正在逼近的感觉。它开始在斯普林菲尔德如何显现出来？巫术在玛丽·帕森斯开始谈论它时悄然降临到了斯普林菲尔德。你知道的，我们对巫术指控开始的方式并没有一种刻板的看法。有时事情出了岔子，他们不喜欢某个人，那个人就被指控并随后受审。但在斯普林菲尔德，情况则相当不同。玛丽·帕森斯开始怀疑其他人，也就是默西·马什菲尔德，后者随后以诽谤罪起诉了她。而玛丽开始对邻居们说，你知道的，她对你的孩子下了巫术，
she bewitched your cow. And they're not having any of that. And they think that it's just wrong to be going on about witches, accusing people indiscriminately and just, you know, just muttering about it the whole time. But I think that this does show that the idea has at least been seeded in people's minds,
她对你的奶牛下了巫术。而他们根本不买账。他们认为，到处谈论女巫、不加选择地指控他人、而且整天只是，你知道的，在那里嘟嘟囔囔，这完全是错误的。但我认为这确实表明，这个想法至少已经播种在人们的心中了，
even if when that first accusation is made, it completely blows up in the accuser's face. So that there is a kind of residue left from this. And as you say, that the idea of Springfield has drifted up the valley, it's drifted across New England, but it's kind of here to stay. You know, they're not going to reverse that just by having a successful slander trial. So Mary is fascinated by witchcraft. She's accused her neighbor of, you know, the marriage has gone sour. They've suffered disappointments, the tragic loss of a child. Samuel, I think it is, isn't it?
即使当最初的指控被提出时，它完全在指控者的脸上炸开了。所以从这当中留下了某种残留物。正如你所说，斯普林菲尔德的想法已经顺着山谷向上蔓延，传遍了整个新英格兰，但它似乎会留下来。你知道的，他们不会仅仅通过进行一场成功的诽谤审判就扭转这一局面。所以玛丽对巫术着迷了。她指控她的邻居，你知道的，他们的婚姻已经破裂。他们遭遇了失望，遭遇了痛失爱子的悲剧。我想那是塞缪尔，对吧？
Their little boy has died. She becomes convinced of two things. One, that her husband is a witch. And secondly, that she is also her witch herself i mean that's an extraordinary to us utterly inexplicable development so what's going on there do you think i think mary undoubtedly is suffering from some kind of mental illness she seems deluded um you know i don't talk about this in the book because i'm trying to sort of stay in their world stay in their categories but the things that she describes, the sort of symptoms that she displays would be
他们的小男孩去世了。她开始确信两件事。第一，她的丈夫是一个巫师。第二，她自己也是一个女巫。我的意思是，对我们来说，这是一个非同寻常的、完全莫名其妙的发展，那么你认为那里发生了什么？我认为玛丽毫无疑问患有某种精神疾病，她似乎产生了幻觉，嗯，你知道的，我在书中没有谈到这一点，因为我试图融入他们的世界，留在他们的分类中，但她所描述的事情，她所表现出的症状将是
consistent with postpartum psychosis, which is much rarer than postnatal depression. And she does seem very strangely deluded. I mean, her husband is horrible. And it does seem that, you know, it wouldn't be strange to infer that maybe he had the devil in him to some extent. But she actually really does start to feel that he has given himself to the devil and he's a witch. He starts to suspect that she is a witch because of the way that she behaves. And also because of, I think, this spiritual wretchedness that we talked about earlier, this sense that can overtake some people of a lack of self-worth, that she starts to believe that she is a witch too. And this would explain some witchcraft accusations we get in the old world too,
与产后精神病相一致，这比产后抑郁症要少见得多。她看起来确实有非常奇怪的错觉。我的意思是，她的丈夫很可怕。而且看起来，你知道的，推断他体内在某种程度上带有魔鬼，这并不奇怪。但她实际上真的开始觉得他把自己交给了魔鬼，他是一个巫师。他开始怀疑她是一个巫师，因为她的行为举止。而且我认为，也因为我们之前讨论过的那种精神上的悲惨，这种能够压倒某些人的缺乏自我价值感的感觉，使她开始相信自己也是一个女巫。这也解释了我们在旧世界中遇到的一些巫术指控，
that people confess freely because they've actually persuaded themselves and others have projected that upon them, that actually they might be a witch against their own will. So Hugh, to go back to him, so you said he's, you know, it would be reasonable to infer that he had the devil in him. And we talked before about him being quiet.
人们坦白认罪，是因为他们实际上说服了自己，而其他人也将这一点投射到他们身上，即实际上他们可能违背自己的意愿成为了女巫。所以休，回到他身上，所以你刚才说他，你知道的，推断他体内有魔鬼是合理的。我们之前讨论过他很安静。
So that quiet is actually what damns him, isn't it? Yeah, to a point. I mean, he's quiet sometimes, but he's actually, I mean, he has to do these brick deals. Everybody wants bricks because, well, one, because wooden chimneys set the house on fire. That's obviously a bad thing. So they want brick chimneys, which are better, but they're also status symbols. So you've got to imagine that there's these men who are hiring Hugh Parsons to build them chimneys. They're very dependent on him. And this is a world where everybody's dependent on everybody else, but it causes difficult relationships. Pension makes
所以那种安静实际上就是他万劫不复的原因，不是吗？是的，在某种程度上。我的意思是，他有时很安静，但他实际上，我的意思是，他必须做这些砖块生意。每个人都想要砖块，因为，嗯，一方面，木制烟囱会让房子着火。这显然是一件坏事。所以他们想要砖砌烟囱，这更好，但它们也是身份的象征。所以你可以想象，有这些男人在雇佣休·帕森斯为他们建造烟囱。他们非常依赖他。这是一个每个人都依赖其他所有人的世界，但这导致了困难的关系。养老金使得
their lives possible, but they kind of resent him too. Hugh Parsons gives them bricks, but they resent that dependence. So there are arguments. Every time Hugh Parsons gives them bricks but they resent that dependence so that there are arguments every time Hugh Parsons goes and does a brick deal he ends up with some kind of row where he threatens them and so that he is you know he's a difficult cantankerous awkward character and then he's quiet you know so it's yeah there's this weird contrast between absolute fury and then this kind of brooding, taciturn mystery about him. And that really is, that's his undoing. The amazing thing about this book, I thought, considering that this is a very obscure place and these are not people who kind of make or shake history, is how vividly you can bring them alive.
他们的生活成为可能，但他们也某种程度上怨恨他。休·帕森斯给他们砖块，但他们怨恨这种依赖。所以总会有争吵。每当休·帕森斯给他们砖块，但他们怨恨这种依赖，以至于每次休·帕森斯去做砖块生意时，都会以某种争吵告终，他在争吵中威胁他们，所以他，你知道的，他是一个难以相处的、好争吵的、别扭的角色，而且他又很安静，你知道的，所以是的，有一种奇怪的对比，绝对的愤怒，然后是一种沉思的、沉默寡言的神秘感。这确实是，那是他毁灭的原因。我认为这本书了不起的地方在于，考虑到这是一个非常偏僻的地方，这些人也不是那种创造或撼动历史的人，你能把他们刻画得如此生动。
And you're doing it on two levels. So you are giving a very, very subtle and complex portrait, say a few. So you describe him, you know, this mixture of ambition and silence. He's forever gauging the scale of other men's estates and debts, dreading falling behind, that he feels a sullen envy that one physician described as a sort of grief mixed with hate. So these are characteristics that we can recognize in our terms. But at the same time, as you said, you want to bring these people alive in terms of the context that would make sense to them. So when you describe Mary, she's in the ale house with other people. And suddenly you say, she consented in her heart to Satan and was transported. And you describe her as though
而且你是从两个层面来做到的。所以你给出了一个非常非常微妙和复杂的画像，比如对其中几个人的描写。所以你描述他，你知道的，这种野心与沉默的结合。他永远在估算其他男人的产业和债务的规模，恐惧落后于人，他感到了某种郁闷的嫉妒，一位医生将其描述为一种夹杂着恨意的悲伤。所以这些特征是我们用我们的术语可以识别的。但与此同时，正如你所说，你希望以对他们有意义的语境来让这些人物复活。所以当你描述玛丽时，她和其他人在小酒馆里。突然你说，她从心底里同意了撒旦并被传送了。你把她描述得仿佛
it's actually happening. Her soul whisked away to a witch's meeting. There's revelry and gleeful shape-shifting from human to animal forms. But the witch is angry with Mary for reeling so much, made her walk barefoot over the stony ground to gather sticks for the fire. So this is a really kind of fascinating tension within the way that you're writing the story, that these are people who are both vividly real. They feel like, you know, they could be characters from a novel and simultaneously you are situating them in a world that is very, very different to the way that we would see the world. Yeah. I mean, the writing of it, I was kind of, you know, I'm walking a line. I mean,
这一切真的在发生。她的灵魂被风驰电掣般带到了一个女巫聚会上。那里有狂欢，还有从人类到动物形态的欢快变形。但是女巫对玛丽摇晃得太多感到愤怒，让她赤脚走在石头地上为篝火收集树枝。所以这在你的写作方式中确实是一种非常迷人的张力，这些人既生动逼真。他们感觉就像，你知道的，他们可能是小说中的角色，而与此同时，你把他们置于一个与我们看待世界的方式截然不同的世界中。是的。我的意思是，在写作它时，我有点，你知道的，我在走钢丝。我的意思是，
I'm trying to communicate to a modern readership, obviously, but there's a difficulty. I mean, I don't believe in witchcraft and I don't believe that many of these things were actually happening, but it's very important that I believe that they believed it. And the danger is sometimes that you spend all this time trying to build up this, you know, this very authentic 17th century world and then you kind of break the spell. You know, it's like breaking the fourth wall and telling the audience, you know, everything's a nod to the reader that actually maybe this was encephalitis or the children were
我显然是在试图与现代读者沟通，但这里有一个困难。我的意思是，我不相信巫术，我也不相信其中许多事情真的发生过，但我相信他们相信这一点，这非常重要。有时危险在于，你花了所有这些时间试图建立这个，你知道的，这个非常真实的17世纪世界，然后你有点打破了魔咒。你知道的，这就像打破第四堵墙，告诉观众，你知道的，一切都在向读者示意，实际上也许这是脑炎，或者孩子们
having were suffering from diphtheria and they called it melancholy but actually she was suffering from clinical depression every time you do that i think it jars so i'm trying to kind of stay within their you know the the reality of their experience, which might sometimes seem a bit kind of coy, I suppose, but actually they are undecided what's going on too. They say what they think is happening, as they discover when they get to court. It's not a consensual world.
患有白喉，而他们称之为忧郁症，但实际上她患有临床抑郁症，每次你这样做，我都觉得这很不协调。所以我试图停留在他们的，你知道的，他们经历的现实中，这有时可能显得有点害羞，我想，但实际上他们也拿不准到底发生了什么。他们说出他们认为正在发生的事情，正如他们在法庭上所发现的那样。这不是一个意见一致的世界。
They're unsure about themselves and their own perception experience, and other people are sceptical about what other people describe. I think the effect is brilliant. It kind of knocks away the sense of superiority that we would feel as 21st century people looking back. And it sucks you into a world in which the devil might be real and witchcraft might be real. And so when in due course, both Mary and Hugh come to be charged with witchcraft, you feel the stakes not just as legal ones, but as kind of supernatural ones as well. What is the process by which Mary and Hugh come to be charged, and indeed in due course convicted,
他们对自我和他们自己的感知体验并不确定，而其他人对其他人所描述的事情持怀疑态度。我认为这个效果太棒了。它打破了我们作为21世纪的人回顾过去时感受到的优越感。它把你卷入这样一个世界：在这个世界里，魔鬼可能是真实的，巫术也可能是真实的。所以当玛丽和休最终在适当的时候都被指控犯有巫术时，你感受到的不仅仅是法律层面的利害关系，还有某种超自然层面的利害关系。玛丽和休被指控并最终被定罪的
of witchcraft? Well, there's this kind of groundswell of opinion, you know, lots of little things all come together. So it's difficult for communities to make accusations because actually the conviction rate in England and in Europe and certainly in New England is actually very, very low, much lower than we'd expect. You know, Malcolm, that was the detail in your book that amazed me the most. It shows just how imprisoned I was by the kind of horrible histories. And actually, funny enough, today, the day we recorded this, I was driving my son to his school bus. I said, I'm going to do this amazing podcast, this fantastic book, Witchcraft. And I said, guess how many people were convicted? And he was way out. He said, oh, nine out of 10 or whatever. I said, no, one in four. Three out of four were acquitted.
过程是怎样的，当然在适当的时候他们因巫术被定罪？嗯，有这种汹涌的舆论浪潮，你知道的，许多小事情汇聚在一起。所以社区很难提出指控，因为实际上在英国、在欧洲、当然在新英格兰，定罪率实际上非常非常低，比我们预期的要低得多。你知道的，马尔colm，那是你书中让我最震惊的细节。它显示了我被那种可怕的历史叙事禁锢得有多深。说来也巧，今天，也就是我们录制这个节目的这一天，我正开车送儿子去他的校车上。我说，我要做一个了不起的播客，一本关于巫术的奇妙的书。我说，猜猜有多少人被定罪了？他猜得离十万八千里远。他说，噢，十之八九或者别的什么。我说，不，四分之一。四分之三被宣告无罪。
That astounded me. So the conviction rate just across europe is about 50 but in england it's lower than it's about 23 24 percent um something similar in scotland it's a bit higher than that but essentially we have this idea that as soon as somebody was accused they must be chased up to the nearest tree and then hanged and this is because this is a modern story it's not a kind of late medieval story these are people whose perceptions of the world are changing. They are gradually changing towards a more empirical way of looking at not just science, but the law as well. So they're very uncertain about evidence. They want to weigh all this up. So when Hugh and Mary are charged or when they're apprehended in Springfield, everybody's
这让我大吃一惊。所以整个欧洲的定罪率大约是百分之五十，但在英国更低，大约是百分之二十三、二十四左右，嗯，苏格兰也有类似情况，比那稍微高一点点，但本质上我们有这样一种想法：一旦有人被指控，他们一定会被追赶到最近的树上然后绞死，这是因为这是一个现代的故事，它不是一个晚期中世纪的故事。这些人对世界的看法正在改变。他们正在逐渐转变为一种更经验主义的方式来看待科学，甚至法律。所以他们对证据非常不确定。他们想要权衡这一切。所以当休和玛丽被指控或者当他们在斯普林菲尔德被捕时，每个人都
kind of reassured everybody else that actually we can do something about this. And this is what witch finders do in the old world. They go around and say to people, you know, I know you're unsure about going to law over this, but trust me, we should do it. People need that reassurance to an extent, you know, far greater than, as you say, we would imagine from a kind of horrible history's view of this, where you think there's a sort of sense of inevitability, of determinism about these accusations. So then they all feel very sure in Springfield, and they get very, very sure of themselves. All this testimony is heard, and then the case is taken to Boston, and they have to kind of prove themselves all over again to a different set of people
某种程度上向其他人保证，实际上我们可以对付这个。这就是旧世界中寻找女巫的人所做的事情。他们四处走动，对人们说，你知道的，我知道你对为此诉诸法律感到不确定，但相信我，我们应该这样做。人们在很大程度上需要这种保证，你知道的，远远超过，正如你所说，我们从这种可怕的历史视角中想象的那样，在这种视角中，你认为这些指控有一种宿命感、决定论。所以他们在斯普林菲尔德都感到非常确信，他们对自己变得非常非常确信。听取了所有这些证词，然后案件被带到波士顿，他们必须向另一群人重新证明自己，
who have a different set of priorities and ideas about what evidence is and therefore what witchcraft is. Well, that's the amazing scene, isn't it? Because they don't all go to Boston. A lot of the witnesses submit written evidence. I love the way that works in the book because you've been building up the tension and the sense of paranoia and that sense of inevitability, I suppose. You know that it's all going to end horribly for Mary and Hugh. She's accusing him and herself of witchcraft. And the book's called The Ruin of All Witches. The spoiler is kind of there in the title. Yeah.
这群人有着不同的优先事项和对证据是什么以及因此巫术是什么的看法。嗯，那是令人惊叹的一幕，不是吗？因为他们并没有全都去波士顿。许多证人提交了书面证据。我喜欢它在书中的运作方式，因为你一直在建立紧张感、偏执感以及那种宿命感，我猜。你知道这一切对玛丽和休来说都会以可怕的方式结束。她指控他和她自己犯有巫术。这本书的名字叫《所有女巫的毁灭》。剧透其实就在书名里。是的。
And the sort of evidence accumulates. So-and-so's milk was saffron-coloured. Somebody fell off his horse. A pudding came out in two pieces. Weird stuff about puddings. Puddings, yeah. But then they get to Boston, and it's exhibited in open court and it's almost as though someone has turned on
各种证据不断累积。某某人的牛奶呈藏红花色。某人从马背上摔了下来。一块布丁裂成了两块。关于布丁的诡异事情。布丁，是的。但后来他们到了波士顿，这些证据在公开法庭上展出，几乎就像有人打开了
an overhead lamp or something and you look at it and you just, and you can see the people in Boston kind of listening to it and thinking, this is pretty thin gruel. Is that because the people in Boston are more sceptical? No.
一盏头顶灯什么的，你看着它，然后你就能看到波士顿的人们听着这些，心里想，这未免也太苍白无力了吧。是因为波士顿的人更怀疑吗？不。
Or is it simply, what is it then? No, it's not scepticismicism of witchcraft again we we can so easily slip into these kind of you know uh 2d view of our ancestors but they they believe absolutely implicitly in witchcraft it's very difficult to unbelieve in witchcraft i think inevitably they feel more skeptical about the evidence so that actually in boston what they say is well this seems like a very good case, you know, but we're just not sure that you've got the right. I'm not going to spoil things too much here, but it just doesn't really stack up.
还是仅仅因为，那到底是什么原因？不，这并不是对巫术本身的怀疑论，我们太容易陷入这种对我们祖先的二维看法中，但他们绝对绝对地相信巫术。我认为，不相信巫术是非常困难的。不可避免地，他们对证据感到更加怀疑，以至于实际上在波士顿，他们说的是，嗯，这看起来像是一个很好的案子，你知道的，但我们只是不确定你们是否抓对了。我在这里不会剧透太多，但这真的站不住脚。
And of course, that's the sort of thing they're saying in England, too. That's why you've got this surprisingly low conviction rate, because, you know, the will to have witchcraft accusations is there the laws there the machinery of the courts is all in place but when it actually comes to it you know nobody in the end really wants to hang an innocent person because then you will bring down the vengeance of heaven the the blood of the innocent will cry out for vengeance as they would say they wouldn't say miscarriage of justice they'd have said something a bit more flowery like that. But it comes to the same thing. They really want to have fair justice. And with witchcraft, it's so difficult to gather that proof. And something of that skepticism about
当然，这也是他们在英国所说的话。这就是为什么你们会看到如此惊人低的定罪率，因为，你知道的，进行巫术指控的意愿是存在的，法律是存在的，法院的机制也都到位了，但当真正到了紧要关头时，你知道的，最终没有人真正想绞死一个无辜的人，因为那样你会招致天堂的愤怒，无辜者的鲜血会呼唤复仇，正如他们所说的那样。他们不会说司法不公，他们会说一些更华丽的话。但归根结底是一样的。他们真的希望有公平的公正。而对于巫术来说，收集那种证据太难了。而对
the quality of evidence has actually been there right from the start of the witch hunt, right back in the early 16th century. And so in fact, neither of them end up being hanged for witchcraft? No, they both kind of escape it. But that in many ways is the typical, you know, that's the typical outcome of witchcraft trials. And again, I suppose that the crucibles kind of skewed this a bit and Salem often stands in for our view of witch hunting and we focus on the tragedy and of course it is a tragedy of the people that we would consider to be innocent being hanged but that's not actually you know Salem is an extraordinary thing it's an aberration most witch trials don't happen at all because they never get as far as the court and then even when
证据质量的这种怀疑，实际上从猎巫行动一开始就一直存在，一直追溯到16世纪初。所以事实上，他们两个最终都没有因为巫术而被绞死？不，他们两个都某种程度上逃脱了。但在许多方面，那是典型的，你知道的，那是巫术审判的典型结果。而且再次，我想坩埚有点扭曲了这一点，塞勒姆经常代表了我们对猎巫的看法，我们关注悲剧，当然，被绞死的人是无辜的，这确实是一个悲剧，但实际上并非如此，你知道的，塞勒姆是一件非同寻常的事情，它是一个反常现象。大多数巫术审判根本不会发生，因为它们从未走到法庭这一步，甚至当
they do get to court we find that more often than not those cases fail. So we don't want to spoil the ending because obviously we want people to buy your book. It was my Sunday Times History Book of the Year, I think a couple of years ago. And it is a brilliant book and I couldn't recommend it too highly. Mary and Hugh, their stories end up in unexpected places, different trajectories, and we're not going to give it away. But witchcraft more generally, well, let's talk about, actually, let's talk about Springfield before we talk about witchcraft. So Springfield, their worst fears do come true, don't they? They're attacked by the Indians and the town is sacked and lots of people are killed. So actually they were right to be paranoid and anxious. You can be paranoid and right.
它们确实闹到法庭时，我们发现这些案件往往以失败告终。所以我们不想剧透结局，因为显然我们希望人们买你的书。我想这几年前曾是我的《星期日泰晤士报》年度历史书。这是一本杰出的书，我怎么推荐都不为过。玛丽和休，他们的故事以意想不到的地方结束，不同的轨迹，我们不会剧透。但更广泛地说，巫术，嗯，让我们谈谈，实际上，在谈论巫术之前，让我们谈谈斯普林菲尔德。所以斯普林菲尔德，他们最糟糕的噩梦确实成真了，不是吗？他们遭到印第安人的袭击，城镇被洗劫，许多人被杀。所以实际上他们的偏执和焦虑是正确的。你可以既偏执又是正确的。
And also Dominic, their founder, Pynchon, gets charged with, basically, with heresy, doesn't he? I mean, he ends up having his books burnt and all that kind of stuff. There's a weird kind of parallel story in this, where the man who seems to be in charge of the witch hunt is himself under investigation for heresy. And really, that's his, you know, you find that actually Pynchon, although he's at the top of this society, and Hugh and Mary who are at the bottom, that really their fates are intertwined and they kind of go down together.
而且多米尼克，他们的创始人平奇恩也被指控，基本上被指控为异端，不是吗？我的意思是，他的书最后被烧毁了，诸如此类的事情。这里有一个奇怪的平行故事，那个似乎负责猎巫的人自己却在因异端接受调查。真的，那就是他的，你知道的，你发现实际上平奇恩，尽管他处于这个社会的顶端，而休和玛丽处于最底层，但他们的命运确实交织在一起，他们一起走向了没落。
And it's just an illustration, actually, of these American lives that they, you know, it's a huge, huge risk. It's a huge gamble. And there are winners and there are losers. And the losers either die or they have to go home. And that's true in pinch's case but pinch and son john does stay on and you know as dominic said that their worst fears do come true and even before then they discover they have this purge of these evil people hugh and mary and then actually they go back to being horrible to each other in new and new and interesting and
这只是一个例证，实际上，在这些美国生活中，你知道的，这是一个巨大巨大的风险。这是一个巨大的赌博。有赢家，也有输家。输家要么死，要么不得不回家。在平奇恩的案子里确实如此，但平奇恩的儿子约翰留了下来，正如多米尼克所说，他们最糟糕的噩梦确实成真了，甚至在此之前，他们发现他们有对这些邪恶之人的清洗，休和玛丽，然后实际上他们又回到了以新的、有趣的和
exciting ways ending each other's land and all that so that actually it doesn't really this is the thing about witch hunts that there's sometimes this rather righteous feeling that actually if we just get rid of those people everything will be all right but it isn't because actually the the wickedness really resides in their own hearts and then in the 1670s this devastating new england widewide war with Native Americans that really does actually nearly spell the end of New England. The native forces get within 10 miles of Boston. If they get to Boston, it would be game over. So this existential threat that's been hanging over them all the time really does reach its climax in the 1670s. Although Springfield recovers, doesn't it,
令人兴奋的方式彼此使坏、侵占彼此土地的老路上，所以实际上这并没有真的，这就是猎巫行动的特点，有时有一种相当正义的感觉，仿佛如果我们除掉了那些人，一切都会好起来，但事实并非如此，因为实际上邪恶真正存在于他们自己的心中。然后在1670年代，这场毁灭性的、席卷整个新英格兰的与美洲原住民的战争，真的差不多成了新英格兰的末日。原住民军队推进到了距离波士顿10英里的地方。如果他们到达波士顿，那就全剧终了。所以这种一直悬在她头顶的生存威胁在1670年代真的迎来了高潮。尽管斯普林菲尔德恢复了，不是吗，
and becomes, I learned from your book the um the birthplace of dr seuss it is yeah he has his own uh memorial sculpture park with life-size sort of cat in the hat and all around the place which is kind of trippy and odd but uh no it's very famous famous for all sorts of other things. Birthplace of basketball and the Merriam-Webster Dictionary, you know, and Rolls Royces were made there. And Springfield Armory made guns for, you know, for generations and generations, right up to the Vietnam War. So it's a really, comes a really thriving town.
并且成为了，我从你的书里得知，嗯，苏苏博士的出生地。是的，他有自己的纪念雕塑公园，里面有真人大小的戴高帽子的猫和周围的各种东西，这有点迷幻和奇怪，但，不，它非常著名，因各种其他事情而闻名。篮球运动和《梅里亚姆-韦伯斯特词典》的诞生地，你知道的，劳斯莱斯也是在那里制造的。斯普林菲尔德兵工厂为，你知道的，一代又一代人制造枪支，一直到越战。所以它确实是一个繁荣的城镇。
And then in the 19th century city too, Dickens goes there. I mean, you know, it's a big civic place. And then, which like so many other American cities, goes into 20th century decline. But Malcolm, another link to cartoons is that, of course, the hometown of the Simpsons is called Springfield. Springfield serves as a kind of, you know, an image of America in every town. And the obvious question, I suppose, that's been hanging over this whole episode is the extent to which what is happening in our Springfield in the 17th century, to what extent are patterns being established that you can trace throughout the entire course of American history, perhaps into the present? What do you think?
然后在19世纪也成了一个城市，狄更斯去过那里。我的意思是，你知道的，这是一个宏大的市民场所。然后，就像许多其他美国城市一样，它在20世纪走向了衰落。但是马尔colm，另一个与漫画的联系是，当然，辛普森一家的家乡被称为斯普林菲尔德。斯普林菲尔德充当了一种，你知道的，美国每个城镇的缩影。我想，一直悬在这个整集之上的显而易见的问题是，17世纪我们斯普林菲尔德发生的事情在多大程度上正在建立可以贯穿整个美国历史、甚至可能延续到现在的模式？你是怎么想的？
Well, I think there are patterns. They're not necessarily uniquely American, though, I think. I mean, they do. One of the things they do achieve in Springfield, like so many other colonial communities, they do recreate old England. They have rather similar patterns of class stratification and manufacture and agriculture and so on. It's often actually really rather similar. You know, the similarity in the end is that people want to belong to something, a society and a community, but essentially want to build their own households. And sometimes they do that comfortably, and sometimes they do it in
嗯，我认为确实有模式。不过，它们不一定是美国独有的，我想。我的意思是，它们的确。它们在斯普林菲尔德取得的成就之一，就像许多其他殖民地社区一样，它们确实重现了旧英国。它们拥有相当相似的阶级分层、制造业和农业等模式。通常实际上真的相当相似。你知道的，最终的相似之处在于，人们想要从属于某个东西，一个社会和一个社区，但本质上是想要建立他们自己的家庭。有时他们很舒适地做到这一点，有时他们通过与
opposition with their neighbours. And that becomes actually, I think, a very modern story about how we all live. But I don't think it's necessarily a uniquely American one. So I know we've spent a lot of time talking about Springfield and what went on in Springfield, but just to broaden it out again at the end, why do people stop having witch crazes? The seeds of the destruction of the witch hunt are really there from the start, which I think, as we talked about earlier,
邻居对立来做到这一点。这实际上变成了，我认为，一个关于我们如何生活的非常现代的故事。但我不认为这一定是一个美国独有的故事。所以我知道我们花了很多时间讨论斯普林菲尔德和斯普林菲尔德发生的事情，但为了在最后再次将其扩展开来，为什么人们不再有猎巫狂热了？猎巫行动毁灭的种子其实从一开始就埋下了，正如我们刚才所讨论的，
is about the uncertainty of having the kind of proof and being confident in the proof that is available, which is essentially witness testimony, which today we would just call hearsay. And I think that by the early that is available, which is essentially witness testimony, which today we would just call hearsay. And I think that by the early 18th century, this development of this awareness of hearsay, of inadmissible evidence in court, really just does for witch hunting. So it's got nothing necessarily to do with the belief in witches. It's really got to do with whether you can translate that belief into action in the courts. And then you find, actually, if there are no more witchcraft convictions, then actually some of the heat goes out of it.
这是关于拥有那种证据的不确定性，以及对现成证据（本质上是证人证词，今天我们称之为传闻证据）缺乏信心。我认为到18世纪初，对传闻、法庭上不可采纳证据的这种意识的发展，真正给猎巫行动画上了句号。所以这不一定与对女巫的信仰有关。这实际上与你是否能将这种信仰转化为法庭上的行动有关。然后你会发现，实际上，如果没有更多的巫术定罪，那么其中的一些热度就会消退。
Witches just don't seem as immediate or present because they haven't been convicted. Of course, the belief in witches and the belief in the supernatural generally goes on in rural communities in america and in england you know beyond the first world war and even actually the belief that there are maleficent witches who may be trying to bewitch your cattle or whatever you know that persists too uh to an extraordinary extent it's just that and sometimes people are lynched um but then of course then the lynchers find themselves on the sharp end of the law rather than the witch. The witch just becomes a victim of abuse and sometimes, sadly, murder. Well, Malcolm, thank you. That was absolutely brilliant. And I think, I mean, I can't recommend The Ruin of All Witches enough.
女巫似乎不再那么迫在眉睫或就在眼前了，因为她们没有被定罪。当然，对女巫的信仰和对超自然现象的普遍信仰在美洲和英国的农村社区中一直持续到第一次世界大战之后，甚至实际上，认为有恶意女巫可能试图对你的牛或其他东西施巫术的这种信仰，你知道的，也一直持续到，嗯，达到惊人的程度。只是，有时人们被私刑处死，但随后私刑施暴者发现自己面临法律的严厉制裁，而不是女巫。女巫只是成了虐待的受害者，有时不幸地成为谋杀的受害者。嗯，马尔colm，谢谢你。这绝对太精彩了。而且我认为，我的意思是，我对《所有女巫的毁灭》的推荐怎么都不为过。
And I think the thing that's most moving about it is the way that you give these figures who had such terrible lives, you give them back a kind of dignity. You talked about Hugh being a kind of terrible man. But there is, I mean, you know, the spectacle of his grief for his children is very, very touching, very, very powerful. So thanks so much for writing it. Thanks so much for coming on the show. And thank you, everyone out there, for listening. Bye bye. Thanks for having me.
而且我认为其中最让人感动的，是你赋予了这些有着如此悲惨生活的虚构人物一种尊严。你谈到休是一个可怕的人。但是，我的意思是，你知道的，他为孩子悲伤的场景非常非常感人，非常非常有力。所以非常感谢你写了这本书。非常感谢你来到这个节目。谢谢外面的每一个人收听。再见。谢谢邀请我。
It's been great. Cheers. Bye bye. Thanks for having me. It's been great. Cheers. Bye bye. Thanks for listening to the rest is history. For bonus episodes, early access, ad free listening and access to our chat community. Please sign up at rest is historyorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just
太棒了。祝好。再见。谢谢邀请我。太棒了。祝好。再见。感谢收听“历史余韵”。想要收听额外单集、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余韵》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的好去处。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚
launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertamment.com。那是 therestisentertamment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。